this week it's King's Quest the first
chapter in the new episodic series by
the odd gentleman and Sierra join me on
the couch Mary Kish and Jeremy Jane to
Questers of kings you guys have played
that game yes if you like done the whole
first episode almost we're both really
close uh well Mary I don't I have been
that I'm yes we're about like three
fourths the way it's actually longer
than I thought it would be which I'm
pleasantly surprised considering that
this is an episodic adventure we were
wondering how long they would be a
couple hours but it's it's about a good
five hour playthrough I would say for
the first chapter give or take and
that's a great amount of time for the
price point that they're they're selling
it's ten dollars and its way longer than
I thought like I i was talking to Mary
yesterday I was playing it for the first
time and I was like oh yeah I'm like
almost done and then she went home and
played it it was like oh you're like at
the beginning oh yeah Jeremy so ten
dollars a pop or forty bucks for the
season pass of five pretty standard
adventure sort of telltale presque
pricing model we're going to talk about
your guys experience with the game we're
gonna like soft-pedal it on the spoilers
obviously haven't finished it and we
know that a lot of you guys are gonna be
wanted to check it out too so it's going
to be pretty spoiler free but want to
talk about like like how you're feeling
about it so far our review is coming
this week but from you guys to people
who have played it you have different
history with the King's Quest series
Mary what's your perspective on this one
right we were talking about this
Jeremy's fresh to the series and I've
played several King's Quest is actually
one of the very first games my father
ever bought for me on pc was Kings
quests seven and it was just this
wonderful magical point-and-click
adventure and I have a lot of wonderful
memories attributed to the King's Quest
series this is like one of the best
parts there's like a mom and a daughter
they're both looking for each other and
this is so standard you're gonna see a
lot of things that you'll actually see
in the current King's Quest kind of
resurfaced the same humor
character-driven story you'll see a lot
of items it's really amazing how many
items you get and similar in the new one
there's about five different puzzles
going on at once here sirrah it's not
linear in this direct sense where your
euro only you will know exactly what
you're supposed to be doing next I'll
get the thing
you use the thing you get another thing
you use that thing that's not how it
goes a lot of times you you're not
really sure exactly what you're getting
all these items for and they're not to
be used for much later so in this one
this is the kind of puzzle where you
needed to find an items that you get
through that pathway and the this King's
Quest it does a very similar thing where
you actually can't get to the next area
until you've found a very particular
item something that they tease to you
and the game does an excellent way of
giving you a lot of clues so there's
more than enough hints along the way so
you're like oh I'm supposed to use this
to get through that bush like that I saw
a long time ago so that I can get to a
well it's all it's all very well done in
the storyline there was almost no time
in this playthrough so far where I've
been like wow nowhere to go by the other
you know the other side of that coin of
course is have there been times when
it's been just so obvious at every turn
that you know where to go that you're
kind of like wit well let me figure
something out here stop giving me so
much information honestly it's so it's
it's a pretty easy game like I feel like
it's like family friendly I don't think
kids would play it and figure it out or
anything but I think like a younger kid
with their parent alongside would not
have too much of a difficult time
playing through but you know the other
side of the coin is there were
definitely times where I was like oh wow
this puzzle is like deceivingly
difficult like there were times where it
got a little more complex on me than I
thought it was going to mm-hmm and
that's one of the things I like most
about King's Quest and again you know
for people who missed that I haven't
played any of the King's Quest games i'm
familiar with them I've seen them play
it I've never played any of them but
this particular one the new one had this
thing going on where it was sort of like
it would be very like disney-esque and
family friendly and the animation is all
like hand-painted environments and stuff
it reminded me of me no kuni a lot
visually but behind it you know it's not
a kids game like there were things going
on and I'm not gonna spoil anything but
you know there are characters who died
unexpectedly and I was like oh my god
and I was like emotionally there was an
emotional toll taken by this death I was
like it feels like a five-year-old kid I
think this would be devastated be a
little upsetting yeah but it does have
that fantastical sort of Disney quality
to it and it is very like just like
magical and like fantasy driven but it
gets down to business there's some real
stuff going on it's interesting cuz the
whole conceit is that you like you're
playing out these memories of the King
he's talk he's telling this to his
granddaughter and so like right from the
getting it does sort of set up that
family dynamic the dynamic of you know
Papa Kish and Mary Kish like sit down
and check it out King's Quest seven kink
ish make sure it makes you feel feel the
field there's there's times where and
acting is just incredibly so much better
for the record for any other kings quest
game you'd be like the writing is pretty
good like the acting questionable but
i'm gonna let it slide is really good
it's christopher lloyd from Back to the
Future is king Graham old King Graham
but they have a lot of the same like the
student these are like these
ridiculously silly characters they do a
really good job this is their plate
they're paying homage to like old comedy
series you'll definitely see pieces of
like the Knights of newman here like it
and all sorts of really cool witty
banter from characters that I don't even
know if they have any value later on but
that's something they're known for is
that you'll you'll hear a story that
might have nothing to do with anything
but it's entertaining and it's enjoyable
to hear I've had such a great time so
far and I really really have likes this
game and so you've been sort of queued
up to expect a certain degree of that
whimsy right of that sort of being punny
of it referencing you know fantasy
tropes and like like it's almost you
know there's a lot of winks to you know
you're also acknowledging that there's a
player playing the game you know Jeremy
I'm wondering how that struck you like
in terms of sort of the overall tone
balancing humor with you no more sort of
dramatic moments so there's a lot of
good sort of like meta humor like you
say it acknowledges that you're playing
a game and so you know for example
there's one thing where there's like two
levers and you have to pick one and
there's no indication of which one you
should pick there's no like hints or
anything it's just 50-50 chance and so
the first time I tried it and I got it
wrong and you know I won't spoil
anything but something unfortunate
happens to the player and actually they
show it in the trailer oh it is like the
first decision you make and also ready
to say there's a skeleton crushed by a
thing next to the one that crushes is
there you did extremely unobservant I
was doing a speedrun Chris no just
King's Quest done quick um but anyway
other than that glaringly obvious hint
I'm is hey you know you are crushed and
it cuts back to old King Graham and
Gwendolyn and he goes and that's what
would have happened if I pulled the left
switch but I'm here so obviously
that's not bad so every time you die in
the game it'll like create some sort of
like elaborate a narrative loophole and
it's like oh but that's not what
happened my favorite one of those is you
get a hatchet at some point and you know
in adventure game like this you're
pointing like you're like trying the
hatch and let me disappear just like
this you're putting on people or
anything and that's the best part is
like so I tried it on one of the other
nights and and you see Graham like wind
up with it and gwendolyn's like in you
you and you cut them and she gave Graham
is like oh no if I didn't do that at all
like I couldn't use the hatchet there
that would have been wrong but it's it's
like it plays off the fact that like I'm
pointing clicks are trying to use
everything on everything and it
definitely doesn't have an abundance of
like like it's it's clear enough without
giving it away that you never feel like
you're like oh I guess I'll just walk
around hatchet in everything until I
figure this out mmm-hmm all right well
this is episode 1 right and so you know
it's sort of it has the task of not just
introducing you to what kind of game
they want to be you know immersing you
in the style and introducing characters
but also of like setting a sort of arc
or hinting at what's to come and you
guys had not quite made it to the end
and you know we want to keep it vague
but like do you feel so far that there's
this is sort of a good kickoff for the
for the series yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm
happy with what I've seen so far I
expect that a lot of these items will
come back in the future previous Kings
quests if you you saw a character that
you loved and maybe you left them and
they were angry with you or something
like that that could end up coming back
for chapters from now and impacting you
it's it's interesting where you you have
no idea yet it's very early on I'm not
really sure they're setting up a lot of
this live-action story right here to
with this girl and her her grandfather
it so you're not really sure exactly
where all these characters in the story
arc is going to go yet but i already
have anticipated recurring characters
things that will probably come back and
and I'm I'm really just excited to see
what's coming but it's a little too soon
to make that call yeah I there are a lot
of choices you make and I'm very hopeful
that the future chapters will hearken
back to the
a lot like I hope that because some of
the choices are clearly just like it'll
change the story a little bit but it
won't impact like that rippling change
of like oh you killed that dude well
guess what you can't do this whole thing
it's not like a life is strange or any
of those other as far as I'm aware where
if you make a decision Alexa was telling
me that if you make a decision in life
is change episode like to you actually
just miss a whole section yeah so 3 and
this doesn't seem the same thing so
Jeremy I'm I on purpose yeah chose
different things to see what the impact
would be and there's this part we if
like find a wheel I found one from one
shop and he found it from another it
made 0 different she was just a choice
came back together I really do hope that
some of those choices do have more
rippling there's another larger decision
it's a dragon later where we both shows
different things and it did have a
different impact so at that stage I'm
not entirely sure if later down the road
if you know if you take down the dragon
or if you help him like how regular
loose now Jack I can help me so those
are things that we just don't know yet
but it's exciting to see how far they're
going to take will the dragon remember
that in the parlance of tell tales okay
I hope he does all right Mary Jeremy
thanks for coming on talking about Kings
quests or a night to remember it is it
is and it's recommended i do recommend
it for as much as though ablated it's
super great value for 10 bucks I'm
saying we don't have a review on the
site yeah I do know it's it's like
really soon it's already in and it's
like up for Q&A so it should be here
really soon but until then Mary kish
recommends it Oh Jerry and I recommend
it it's really cool and it's fun
delightful very cool our kings quest
review will be up shortly it's out now
on steam and consoles consoles consoles
it's coming to consoles it's maybe not
out of consoles now shouldn't done my
research there's a PlayStation but not
Xbox net your Amish on consoles so the
xbox a hundred percent and ps4 code
didn't work but I think it is going to
be working too yeah yeah cool King's
Quest a night to remember
you